c'est un portrait de femme là
différentes conceptions du portrait de
la femme il ya celle là et puis la vôtre
chantal akerman avec votre film qui
s'appelle je vais essayer de me tromper
jeanne dielman 23 qui est des commerces
bruxelles 1080 bruxelles et le portrait
de femme c'est delphine seyrig qui
commence pour définir si vous demandez à
toutes les deux de faire quelque chose
de très difficile voire impossible c'est
à dire de résumer en quelques minutes de
télévision un film qui fait 3 heures 20
mai qui a raison de faire un jardin car
la durée fait partie même du sujet du
film
oui j'ai commencé alors le film ces
trois journées de la vie d'une femme
qu'elle lui très très organisés bardet
contre le hasard cette femme vit seule
avec son fils et les veuves et depuis la
mort de son mari elle a continué
exactement à vivre la même manière que
comme s'il était là parce que il n'ya
pas obligatoirement la nécessité d'un
homme pour que si vous voulez on joue
son rôle
l'euro symbolique est tellement fort bon
et dont toute façon pour continuer à
vivre elle reçoit des hommes de 5 heures
à 5 heures et demie tous les jours sauf
le week-end et si vous voulez organiser
son temps de manière à ne pas laisser
trop et au bout de l'afld
enfin la deuxième journée tout cet
univers très organisé ça commence s'est
insidieusement déréglé et à ce moment là
il y aura un trou dans son horaire qui
laissera le pantalon angoisse la
réflexion qui débouche flanc gauche il
ya une série d'actes manqués si vous
vouliez son inconscient et commence à
parler tu es pas retenter le nord si
vous avez une série qu'est ce qui nous a
jamais dire séduit des mots séduction
n'est peut-être pas le vent terme mais
s'il fait partie du pacifique en rien
mais qu'est ce qui vous a motivé pour
accepter un rôle
vous êtes totalement comme on dirait le
banaliser des starisé est rendu à la
quotidienneté
oui
je sais pas si c'est bon c'est la
première fois pour moi qu'on traite ce
sujet voilà c'est un il est très rare
qu'on vous propose un film dont le sujet
n'a jamais été traitées avant je pas si
vous avez remarqué qu'on traite souvent
les mêmes sujets oui les archétypes là
c'est vraiment la première fois qu'on
traite ce sujet c'est une nouveauté pour
moi faut pas seulement pour moi mais je
suis surtout aux spectateurs ils n'ont
jamais vu ce sujet traité d'aucune
manière
il y aura sûrement d'autres films faits
sur ce sujet après celui de chantal mais
c'était la première à l'avoir fait mon
avis qui est le sujet étant la femme
d'intérieur sa vie quand elle est chez
elle ses occupations
les pubs les plus les plus passionnés
disons ce qui est ce qui la concerne le
plus au monde et il ya des jeux déjà
plusieurs milliards et non moins bien
sommes-nous sûrs tels un milliard et
demi ou deux milliards de femmes qui qui
qui mène cette vie et se trouve très
intéressant que pour une fois on
commence à avoir pensé tout à fait
passionnant et et déroutant et on le
voit dans la durée réelle il ya même des
gens qui vous diront que c'est pas du
tout comme ça qu'ils savent pas et des
gens qui en général sont des hommes sont
au bio toute la journée qui donc ne gêne
absolument pas ce qui se passe chez eux
pendant la journée
j'ai entendu des hommes bien mais c'est
absolument improbable c'est absolument
une histoire impossible ça n'existe pas
aucune femme née comme ça ou alors c'est
une folle ou et son fils et un bon on
n'avait jamais je crois que c'est la
première fois qu'on aborde sa donc
forcément les gens ne croient pas à la
vérité destin puisqu'il faut préciser
que c'est un film qui fait dans sa durée
réelle va vous presque je veux dire par
là on va prendre un exemple
finalement vous faites des escalopes
l'année c'est de bonne guerre oui vous
faites vraiment des escalope panée le
temps réel qu'il faut pour faire des
escalopes année vous prêter comme ça ça
s'est déjà fait dans des dans des
documentaires sûrement sur les escalopes
année là c'est pas du tout ça non mais
je pense que non mais tous les gestes du
quotidien sont rendus restituer dans
leur durée réelle
oui on a trouvé que c'était
exemple pour moi par exemple ce film a
touché des tas de points très concrets
parce que j'ai refusé cette vie très
rapidement vous aussi d'ailleurs je
pense alors voilà donc moi je l'ayant
refusé je me suis trouvé à faire du kc
j'avais je ne sais pas de casser chez
moi je bois du thé et quand les gens
boivent du café chez moi c'est d'une
efficacité et je me suis trouvé à faire
du café pour la première fois de ma vie
et ça a été ça a été une une opération
très concrète et presse et tous des
choses autrement dit ce que je
ce que j'essaye de dire très mal c'est
que ce sont des choses qu'on a accepté
comme étant faite par un certain nombre
de personnes sur la terre qui sont en
grande majorité des femmes etc alors qu
en fait sont pas des choses du tout à
accepter comment dire qu'en face les
femmes qu'ils font tous les jours ça ce
que je veux dire je suis sûr parce que
elles doivent elles doivent croire que
que tout le monde trouve ça naturel
qu'elles fassent toutes ses occupations
en fait c'est tout ce qui a deux pas
naturellement je veux dire mais quand
vous dites les hommes qui ont vu cela un
réflexe les annales et c'est pas
possible c'est pas comme ça vous vous
chargez mais vous avez du rôle d'un
préfet dans la mesure où vous vient de
me le dire vous même vous n'avez pas
cette vie là non je ne trouve pas que
c'est chargé du tout bon moi je ne mène
pas cette vie là parce que je les
refuser et je l'admets parce que vous
avez le maire de refuser parce que j'ai
les moyens là naturellement la plupart
des femmes n'ont pas les moyens de ce
problème a le choix
oui oui alors là on sent bien qu'ils ont
très lointaine qui est qu'à ce moment là
les femmes souvent se marie aussi parce
qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens de faire
autrement oui mais enfin dans la mesure
où je on peut percevoir ce recevoir ce
film comme un film de défense de la
femme film attention tellement parlé
c'était j'avais l'impression qu'elle
qu'elle montrait ce qu'elle avait vu
faire toute ma vie par les femmes autour
d'elle
et c'est au niveau de la distance ni
pour attaquer c'était c'était vraiment
un super mec il émouvait qui se doivent
d'être c'est à dire que si vous lire
c'est le film est fait à partir des
images de mon enfance que j'ai
enregistrée j'ai vu des femmes de dos
pencher important des paquets et si vous
voulez ce que je pense qu'il est
différent d'eux un homme n'aurait pas
fait ça je pense un homme parce que dès
son enfance je lui apprends que les
vraies valeurs sont pas là qu'on fait
pas de l'art avec une femme qui fait la
vaisselle
moi j'ai pris pas pris le contre-pied
consciemment j'ai fait ce qui
m'intéressait et ça donne le résultat